previously on TV sins Morty
turn me so we're making eye contact God
made you special and he loved you very
much don't let any of those things get
away Morty and be sure to keep the
garage door open all these things scurry
about that seems to propel a lot of our
plots also is this a garden hose hanging
on the side of the Smith house that
thing is huge how does the girthy estar
hose ever to hose a yard can we call it
dirt Diggler hi Morty Smith invoke my
right to choose one in every 10 Rick and
Morty adventures so it's true Rick and
Morty have adventures that are not
televised so it's possible we haven't
seen other adventures chosen by morning
but the episode meeseeks and destroy'
seemingly established that Morty would
choose at least one adventure in every
10 episode season when Morty angled to
be in charge of every third adventure
and Rick casually rebutted him off with
every tent this self-aware show was
surely referring to the number of
episodes in a season I think they just
forgot this was a thing until now this
time-travel box hasn't paid off and I'm
calling it it's been long enough I want
some time-travel shenanigans damn it
this container has been teasing me since
episode 1 and my flux is at full
capacitor they did a hole indicators
without us bunch of them got killed too
so Morty is an unabashed of indicators
fan and while it makes sense that they
would do an adventure without Rick and
Morty seems like he would have figured
that out already since he's such a huge
fan of them in all Whitney have various
news feeds set up to follow whatever The
Vindicator were doing even when they
weren't assembled yikes yeah things did
feel less diverse in there sure there's
a white guy but there's also a woman who
was apparently a solar system a person
made of ants a robot crocodile and a
ghost train conductor of color what the
hell is Rick even talking about I'll buy
that supernova and Vance can fly down
from the jet pan I guess maybe million
ants can somehow float down with Morty
and tow but kinda Allen rails and Crocky
body even come close to surviving the
impact of that height are you alright
yes I only lost 400 ants million ants is
made up of a million ants this mini
bullet-holes would have caused the
slaughter of well into the tens of
thousands my queen is lame or I am back
to 1 million ants
literal ant man could have had any kind
of biology and it would make sense I
suppose I mean this guy is made up of
ants but no ants have to go through the
larvae and pupae stages before
developing into full-blown ants this
whole process lasts a month at least so
even if your queen could somehow spit
them out that fast your chronology needs
some work she's supernova I mean there's
realistic body image and then there is a
toilet paper roll balancing two
cantaloupes while sitting on top of the
Great Pumpkin is your superpower
transmitting body dysmorphia we're
taking fire from an automated turret can
you bring it offline seems like they
wouldn't need Rick to do this since many
of the superheroes have powers that
could easily destroy the turret on their
own but this episode is a parody of
superhero movies so maybe that's the
point I'm sending in anyway because I
won't feel right in the morning if I
don't okay so the turret shoot the decoy
and it absorbs the bullets but why did
they stop shooting once the decoy goes
back into the box
these guns clearly have more bullets
left because they end up blowing
themselves up after Rick's hilariously
complicated device locks them down so
what point does Rick transition from
hilarious nihilistic [ __ ] to
legitimate supervillain has he always
been the villain of the show look that's
fine if that's the case I'm just saying
at some point we need some sort of moral
foundation here right
this is triggering me I need space does
anyone even want to just glance at the
board and maybe just do the easy
matching game I'm as stubborn and
prideful as the next guy but if my
life's on the line I'm at least gonna
check out the difficulty level before I
get all flustered look I know the drunk
Rick set all this up and all this is
surprising to him - but sober Rick
doesn't care one bit about these
[ __ ] so why is he all horrified
about Vance the Rick we know and love
would be stoic about this and be ready
with a sarcastic quick one reason
watchin trust you'll invite because my
epidermis is laced with the Nano
favorite defense mesh okay that's
awesome
but when he grabbed your neck your
eyeball went to bloodshot which means
your defense mesh wasn't working when he
first grabbed you what appears to only
exist for this joke of course we're
going to keep our eye on that clock and
now it appears to be under a minute even
though only one minute has passed since
the three minutes starting this is like
the friend's apartment quiz all over
again except Rick's more likeable than
Ross dude
this game doesn't even have a timer why
the rush even drunk pickled Rick is a
super genius but he's just one super
genius right how does one person build
this entire fully automated giant
instructional screen and an interactive
holographic display in one drunken night
drunk version of me is probably so
supportive of Israel he wants what's
best for it and hey man I'm not touching
this that's a funny reply but does
million ants know the geopolitical
complexity of issues concerning Israel
to the point that he knows it's a touchy
subject five 3-pointers in five minutes
sir I don't know the whole place was all
planned
caught up with a neutrino bomb Rick
clearly recorded his audio first making
it up as he went and then had to enact
his ramblings into the real world which
is kind of brilliant considering that's
basically how their show seems to be
created so this is either a sin for Rick
standing in as the proxy for the writers
laziness or assume for being brilliant
not to get away with it either way
Oh disarm the drunkenly improvise
neutrino bomb Morty how many of these
how many Rick too many okay so he's
disarmed a few of these bombs but where
the hell is he all of a sudden going
full hurt locker when we all know
non-drunk rick is the one that will
eventually take care of this is there
something set up on this basketball
court that detects the distance from
which these guys shoot the basket
because it seems like they could just
shoot layups and everything rigged up
here wouldn't know the difference I mean
if it allows supernovae to treat the
three-pointers like this then there's
nothing stopping them from taking the
easiest shot possible because when
you're an [ __ ] it doesn't matter how
right you are nobody wants to give you
the satisfaction being overheard at TV
zooms team-building retreat somehow
makes it into a Rick and Morty script
wouldn't Rick's nano fiber defense mesh
easily be able to break these handcuffs
so Morty gets on the platform and it
works but we find out that drunk Rick
was thinking of noob noob as the answer
to this question and well this game
might just be total bull then that's
exactly the point of it all this whole
thing is so detailed you think if drunk
Rick was really thinking about knew of
noob he'd have made sure the platform
required Nobu every single puzzle Rick
setup was accompanied by a video and
every single one of these recordings
took place in history and while he may
not have had every game plan he clearly
had the last game plan because he had
already cut out the rainbow background
for the last video message but that last
one was accorded somewhere in the cave
they're currently in so why did he wait
to do this one here when he did all the
other videos in his garage you were
always the romantic which is why you
can't leave either
so supernova is a full-blown psychopath
now just like that was there any sign of
this over her years of service this is a
sin for The Vindicator
HR department if nothing else I'm going
to enjoy this wouldn't all the people up
here have seen supernova doing all the
evil she did including killing million
ants while they took the ride on the
elevator
you mean nobody was looking down during
that whole thing and what about the
superheroes nobody looked up and saw
tons of people up there having a party
and
cooking one of the hottest talents out
there logic I mean there's logic
problems and then there's logic problems
apparently this episode has both when
you're the middle child in a family of
five million you don't get any attention
its Maximus renegade star soldier that
man is playing Galaga thought we
wouldn't notice but we did there's a
classic case of guy on the ground
obviously I came here last night during
a blackout man so this is what the zone
feels like Oh analyze this fence stay
calm wake up you made a deal with a
force that's bigger than you when the
time comes they're gonna ask you to pay
what they feel you owe them it's for the
greater good